which ain't Silent Bob reboot man was it
it's coming I was watching and like
first of all four people want to get
tickets it's on fathom events so if
you've got a fathom events calm slash
reboot it's in theaters October 15th and
it's one of those deals where it's a
special event October 15th and October
17th
yeah and October 19th that's the fat
events thing where you could see it in
any multiplex around the country yeah
then October 19th Jay and I go out on
the reboot Roadshow tour where we take
the movie 60 right now 62 cities I think
we're adding like three more before it's
done so 65 says like a legit tour man
you like doing those tours the first
week I did red state was the first day
me and we did it well but we didn't like
we were like we got 10 dates and then
we're done and it's like no we should
just keep going and you watch the film
every time yeah and this time really
looking forward to watching this one
each time because I love the movie I'm
so deeply in love with it's meant to be
like a big when I had the heart attack
and I was laying on the table and the
doctors like you know you have 80%
chance of dying tonight I was like oh
good lord they said to me every time I
perform okay with it I'd reached a place
of peace where I was like wow if I died
tonight so bad I've had a really good
life and then I was like wait a second
though if I do die tonight the last
movie I made was yoga hose or sofa I was
like I gotta live doc I gotta make Jay
and Silent Bob reboot so the movie
became like this everyone hates when I
say it but it's I can't think of
anywhere that way to describe it's not
that you shouldn't put it on the poster
it's not real a good marketing hook but
to me it's a big fat cinematic
gravestone like I was gonna say
love-letter gravestone good way to put
it it's like me going like this was my
whole life like the movie is tracks
every flick I've ever done it's
equalizes clerks Mallrats chasing amy
even Dogma and Jay and Silent Bob strike
back talks about the podcast my family's
in a J's families and it stuffs like a
big
scrapbook like I kind of went at it when
I was making it like this is it cuz you
know my old man had two heart attacks
the first one he made it through in a
second when he didn't I've changed my
life one feegan lost a bunch of weight
but at the end of the day I'm subject to
the fact my parents gave me a brunette
ecstatics as it is so if the second one
comes back and then does me in
regardless of
much I've changed my lifestyle I wanted
to make something that was like here it
is this is my eulogy last will and
testament so making of this movie do you
ever see a big fish yeah of course last
10 minutes a big fish with carrying
albert finney through his life that's
what the whole making this movie was
like everybody I know and loved ever
came back and stuff like that and they
all came down in New Orleans I got to
play with all my old toys again it was
so wonderful after the heart attack I
felt like an old man and so I was like
you know what I'll pull out the toys
this will make me feel do you like being
a vegan because I've thought of it like
because I like animals so much I know I
do I I choke you know like wherever on
stage I'm sure I'd do it I didn't do it
here because we're all pros but like you
know out in the world my go-to joke is
like I'm vegan now you used to be happy
now I'm [ __ ] vegan so but I it is a
joke I actually like being vegan I don't
miss anything I'm never like home and if
only I could have that there's enough
options out there for us fake meats and
see does that hold not i've had burgers
in miami stripped about of my head so
did you wanna I'm glad you're here Jason
because the movie you know it opened and
it's in the trailer so it's not like a
spoiler but when we first are
reacquainted with Jay and Silent Bob Jay
has his dick tucked back his pants down
is that something where you were like
look we need to let everybody know that
the Jay and Silent Bob are here and this
is what they're up to in 2019 and we
need we need your dick tucked back Jay
this is it's necessary I mean I wish it
was my idea but it was Kevin's he loves
seeing my mangina tuxes watch me a few
times he masturbated to me touching my
mangina no it's not true but I do think
I'm like I just went so far as to say
like I would [ __ ] you and then you
tailor it back by going he jerked off
believed that not in a chair when the
server becomes the mast
but you sign your right okay yeah I love
I mean again it's it's been fun the only
one that I was a little I wouldn't even
do two movies I'd be on the street where
this all started and when we first met I
he used to beg I'm gonna go get a balls
I'd go to his house and harass him
except like hanging out with him when I
was younger he had a big wall of comic
books like hundreds and hundreds and a
bunch of movies and stuff and then I'd
go over and be in his room he but don't
touch anything
and then he go in the room to like grab
something come back and I we let sit in
there my man penis talked and I bet I
didn't touch anything bro but look I
gotta be driving around with you like is
it hot in here I'm like no why and you
look over and it's like dick is out this
really wise you're like this is this is
your life to yourself you're like you
know what that mangina I played a very
important role in my life I've seen his
dick and lack of dick more than I've
ever seen my dick
there was so many like because like you
know the whole universe that you guys
created with these characters like that
was like pretty much anybody in my
generation or whole high school
experience you know what I mean so we're
like in love with the whole thing so
when I turned it on and it's just like
every character ever
and then the references like you got so
detailed there's a scene where you're
eating chocolate and it's just even in
the way you're licking your fingers yes
I called mall rats like every size I
thought immediately I was like really
that was my direction to him in the car
remember in the car I was just like hit
each finger like Rooker did and Mahler
yeah like I rewound it just to be like
what was that just in my head it is more
full of Easter eggs than the last ten
Easter's like it's just packed with in
jokes and stuff are there any that no
one has gotten yet or no one has
commented Kevin started seeing it with
the audiences yet like October 19th when
we start the tour that'll be the first
time we didn't even test green or
anything like that for all I hope to god
it's good scene it seems like it but we
haven't done this thing where it's like
let's just show it to fans we're about
to start that so I look forward to see
if they get everything and they
absolutely
well I mean if you grab that I grabbed
it that's that's that's pretty sweet
yeah
was there anybody that was tough to get
back into doing this thing so I feel
like if you don't have everybody you
don't have anybody yeah yeah there's you
know honestly like the heart attack
really helped in that degree and as much
as like you'd call people be like a man
can you come thank you can you come down
to New Orleans for like two hours to be
in our movie they're like New Orleans
that's pretty [ __ ] far and he'd be
like you do remember I almost got
[ __ ] Coleman I'm coming so a lot of
folks came back like it was crazy but
then there were folks that I didn't even
think we're coming back who did
eventually come back like when I wrote
the script and we went into production
there was no holdin Ben wasn't gonna be
in the movie and it was seeing him on a
junket somebody sent me a tweet of Kevin
McArthur who does like press junkets all
the time he's out of Washington he's
like their movie reviewer on the news
there he anytime he interviews somebody
who's been in one of our flicks he
usually kind of starts with like a view
skew reference so if he's interviewing
Matt he's just like hey man when you're
gonna start Good Will Hunting 200 season
you can see it on his face is like Good
Will Hunting and there's a Oh James I'm
Bob check back you know Kevin Mullin and
so it makes I guess for a better
interview so it with Ben he was
interviewing for this Netflix show
called triple frontier and right off the
bat he was like hey man they're shooting
that reboot did they call you yet and
Ben was like no and I'm around I'm not
busy but nobody's called and so right
away he was like you have to vote could
call him dude that's a saw and I was
like that's not sign that's just some
nice [ __ ] to say to junk it like was he
supposed to say [ __ ] those guys anyway
watch triple frontier you know it's
you've been talking to him in a while
right a while like almost 10 years did
you get him did I get who Ben did we get
him in the movie yeah we absolutely
didn't yeah we did we did so you did
call him something tells me you didn't
see the movie
I got you do bones I could watch and
enjoy you think it he wasn't gonna do it
well yeah I didn't even write him into
the script cause I done spoken of them
and so [ __ ] long so I didn't even
write Holden in or anything like that
and then for a week
Jason and his wife Jordan she's Bruce
around the movie they kept saying you
should reach out to him you should reach
out to him and finally I was like all
right you know I'll tweet him and I
wrote this long tweet and then they were
Jordan was like don't [ __ ] tweet I'm
that's so gross like just text him I was
like I got four numbers I don't know if
any of them work and she's like pick one
I picked one you know it's great if it's
the wrong number and it went to somebody
else somebody got the Kevin Smith Ben
Affleck text oh yeah it's awesome when I
was texting with this person I didn't
know it was him there's no salt like he
sent me a photo and stuff he started
responding I was like is this still you
and he's like yeah this may who's this
and I said who are you
and he said BA and they said this is
your father and then I knew it was a
Flex that's kind of [ __ ] he says like
who's your father and so he goes who's
this and I was like ah you know this
conversation ends right now probably and
I wrote KS and he was like Kevin I said
yeah he's like how you doing man I said
great I was about to tweet you this so
I'll just text it here and I texted it
like I was like we're all having a blast
here in the past and wish you were here
but ever since our attack on wishing
tomorrow just ask so will you please
come down and play with us like it'd be
so amazing to see you again I've quoted
The Good King Osric from Conan the
Barbarian I was like there comes a time
when the jewel ceased to Sparkle the
gold loses luster the the throne room
becomes a prison all an old director
wants to do is make to him with his
buddies and he wrote back instantly goes
it's so telling that you still think of
yourself as a king I'd love to come play
and he came down and joined us man it
was nuts oh I got to write that scene
didn't even exist when we started making
the movie and then you know suddenly I
got to put it in I got to include him I
got to make a eight-minute chasing a me
sequel in the middle of the movie it was
just wonderful
yeah now it's fun watching a director
dude like what Tarantino did with Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood like well you
know he's just kind of going down these
weird yeah little corridors that he
wants to go down that's kind of fun to
watch somebody do well you know the
little things that they want to like he
wants to make a [ __ ] Western in the
middle of his movie he wants to do this
he wants to make a movie
but you didn't watch our I was just
hoping that would you have to talk to
Clinton no they sent us a link but I
didn't know it when they sent it I
realized that we had been sent a link in
that movie watch it we watched someone
go watch a movie like Sharon Tate
remember yeah yeah leave it all in no
just let it roll I'm happy with my kid
was in that movie so I was like yeah
yeah who is your kid Emily she played
one of the man said because she was
froggy uh how old she's 20 oh wow okay
which one was trying to remember I don't
I didn't get all the names was she just
one of the ones in the group yeah I'd
like one or two lines but she's in it a
lot there's like Hollywood kids in it
Uma Thurman's kid is one of the Manson
members right like I think there was a
theme he had going on he Fromm's nice so
your eye I mean your daughter's
obviously in this one too yeah we as she
right after Quentin's movie we went and
made this and she got to great great to
hear from a daughter dad I'm gonna need
to lay shooting on your whatever you got
going on I have a Tarantino movie when
she told me she wanted to be in it she
was like I want to try out for this
movie she took I've been reading books
about the subject I watched a
documentary as it was a movie she said
once upon a time in Hollywood I was like
oh my god kiddo
lower your expectations what are you
[ __ ] kidding me I want to be in that
everyone wants to be in that movie Matt
is a tough one to get into instead I
always tell you to like you know go for
your dreams but like I don't know like
this one
so she auditioned for it and stuff and
eventually got the part and I was just
like well [ __ ] me what do I know did
being your daughter help her I don't
know I haven't spoken to him I you know
he'd the way I heard the story was she
auditioned they don't give you lines to
audition with they just he says make up
a monologue for your character so she
went in made the monologue for a
character and he responded to that at
first he was like ah she's too young we
don't really have anything for it and
then like two weeks later he's like you
know what I like it a lot of my finder
plays for her so what I heard when she
told me that you know I was like hey man
that's great Congrats like cuz she must
be an actress she's been acting for a
while and I'm like thinking about acting
is like you know you put your [ __ ]
fate in somebody else's hands you you're
waiting to get chosen by some
buddy Alice's [ __ ] that [ __ ] waiting to
get chose and choose yourself like
you're my kid I didn't wait to get
chosen otherwise would be sitting quick
stop still just went made a [ __ ]
movie Ben and Matt didn't wait to get
chosen you could [ __ ] write write for
yourself so she never really listened
and then after this thing with Quentin I
was like all I hear in that story is
like one of the greatest writers in this
business responded to a monologue that
you wrote she make it up on the spot or
before I do you know like a week before
you go and I gotta make she wrote it and
Tarantino's going like that it's good
that's that's what I heard I'm saying
like when she told me that story I'm
like look I'm glad you got a part in a
movie but like that guy responded to
your content right yeah yes that right
old [ __ ] movie [ __ ] waiting for
somebody to cast you and stuff and I
mean you write your father about like
Tarantino being able to go down those
roads the same thing you're doing with
chainsaw bob is saying she was able to
just do with the Netflix movie Irishman
you do that for years and now Netflix is
like here's all the money on in 50
million dollars good god but you know
what I ain't complaining are you know I
want to see every one of them dollars on
that screen yeah they're so good but
just the idea of like several different
avenues and
for creators just getting to create it's
probably the closest thing to going back
to making clerks when it was like nobody
was paying attention and I could just go
make this movie right now
the closest thing to making clerks is
tusk nobody was paying attention nobody
thought that was the one where the like
on clerks I didn't nobody's paying
attention and I didn't once think like
what will happen to this every other
movie are always thinking about like
after that like critics and box office
and all that [ __ ]
tusk I didn't have any of those thoughts
I all I thought was like I just want to
see this movie which was the same spirit
through which I made clerks like I'm I
just want to see it I don't give a [ __ ]
about what happens or anything like that
so this one was more about reboot was
more about like like the greatest
highschool reunion that we never had
with like all of our friends and and and
instead of being like oh it sucked
everybody got laid and we were like
let's do it again next year it was just
phenomenal it's awesome in addition how
are you doing in what way Asian life you
look good you look healthy thank you
thank you
good I'm uh you know doing it I've had a
lot of fun on the movie and now you know
we're doing all getting ready for the
the reboot Roadshow you know I'm home
mainly hanging out with the kid my kids
4 and a half now man and it's literally
my like I'm either streaming I've been
streaming out doing twitch oh we used to
check it out but I've been streaming
which has been a lot of fun I've been
like doing a different stuff but mainly
building Legos people are like that's my
new wow they watch you do it and pay you
right or they tip you to do it or take
off your shirt in the bricks hang on
honey I got to make these gold coins
what do you want me to do very zen
they're like look at him he's just
because he's sitting there quietly like
he's not even narrating and he's just
building his Legos and I feel like
meditating to him yeah so that's been a
lot of fun but well I'm home I've been
doing that and hanging out with my kid
and getting ready to go on this you know
the tour which is gonna be like two
months solid or so we're gonna be gone
so you didn't Kevin you you weren't a
big weed guy when Jay and Silent Bob
first started right no even when even
when we made Jay and Silent Bob strike
back like if you watch that whole movie
there's like one real weed joke in it
we're like they get high with the Scooby
Gang and it looks like it's done by
somebody who's never really spent much
time more like it looks like other
movies you've seen and this is the first
movie view askew movie set in the you
know with our characters Jay and Silent
Bob and what not that I ever made as a
STONER so the movie is much more weed
friendly and accurate there's actually a
weed plot line that runs through are you
smoking a lot still Oh crazy hard not to
bet eat bad when you're all [ __ ] high
oh I just I don't combine those two at
all in fact one substitutes for the
other those days I'm like do I want to
eat or I want to smoke my lunch [ __ ] it
I want to smoke okay yeah so we in the
movie the boys have three strains of
weed snoogantay poochie's in berserk
that play a part of the plot and then we
brought them into the real world on
Friday we just introduced our weed you
know to the weed legal States in
California being one of them and stuff
so we had this big like premiere party
at this dispensary called their barium
with like a thousand people showed up it
was dope
so we brought our weed into the I'll
show it to you but I'm gonna keep my
weed smoochie boo cheese look at that oh
wow Teva has got us on it and stuff then
we've got a snoo guns as an indica and
berserker as the hybrid so do you feel
like this will be your legacy at the end
of the day and so people will forget
this [ __ ] and still be smoking this
week right cuz caviar Gold powers the
weed they're the guys that make such
amazing [ __ ] weed so they're they're
kind of the source behind it so yeah I
think people forget about this flick and
the weed will be its legacy I just loved
it like all of your movies by certain
people have been called stoner comedies
and this is it you've never been
technically like the first stoner comedy
ever made was tusk and that's not even a
comedy now but it is a stoner Affairs
like that movie don't exist unless I'm
like this big old movie about a guy
another guy war is that me [ __ ] up
between films was this between this new
one and the one you did before that you
said was you don't want to be your last
one
yoga hozier yoga's that was came out in
2016 and now we're 2019 not three years
about three you do not like yoga I love
you people of [ __ ] mitts mouth I feel
like so far with nowhere to go but up
with this movie and this movie is
incredibly self-indulgent like I'm
literally in every frame of the movie
when I'm not Silent Bob I'm playing
[ __ ] Kevin Smith in the movie I think
the only time I get away with this movie
is post heart attack
people who want to like be like [ __ ]
camera are gonna be like well he did
almost die let him have this book did
you really mention the heart attack when
you texted Ben Affleck LaHaye ever since
the heart attack on the truck in the
movie good for you it's in part of the
plot I mentioned the heart attack like I
was telling somebody the other day was
the car detects the biggest thing
they're rapin me since clerks clerks for
25 [ __ ] years and now I could be like
oh and I had a heart attack
yeah two things happen today you got
Matt Damon to come back as well he was
coming back regardless I see he's always
been fairly cool with this but we didn't
know how we're
gonna use them at first I was just gonna
use them as like Matt Damon right and my
wife is like how come you never think to
use him as Loki from Dogma is it cuz
Loki died and she's like in a movie and
was I called [ __ ] you I made up this
whole you should I need I don't have a
heart attack to get into it I need
something I can tell my like like you
know Kevin Hart about these things that
he could get me get that sympathy yeah
erection difficulties is not cutting it
right that for years I remember one
point in my life somebody said I forget
who was but they were like you could
always have a second act in this
business and I was like I'm I think I'm
on my ninth what do you mean yeah
they're like just the way to change the
conversation you could lose weight one
day and I was like oh I'd never do that
and then post heart attack I went vegan
then lost the way and it did create a
whole different conversation
I literally just interviewed with Muscle
& Fitness of course she did one more
gemandsam catch up with full episodes
and interviews from celebrity guests
anytime on demand using the Sirius XM
app